[Music]
and also churu news submitted by mucho
man lost his airline miles for sneaking
his fat cat on a flight how did he sneak
it so he devised a plan okay so first of
all he was on a layover in Moscow Moscow
funny you see a Russian cat in another
Russian yeah yeah that's aw captain like
yeah yeah yeah pink cats fly or just
dogs yeah oh I in my head where girl
they have four legs they're not angel
Stacey's animals are angels yeah they
are come rain cats and dogs yeah yeah
you're right they just fall yeah so so
he was flying with his 22 pound cat
named Victor Oh 22 pounds is [ __ ]
fish okay okay your son is 30 pound a
really free something what does that
look like it looks like like it's like
all free and brown and like fluffy like
very fluffy and I don't know how to
describe it like that sounds like any
cat girl no it's like it's like brown
fur they have stretchy but goddamn black
like I can get a text right and they
have the like typical okay so like some
cuts no fur goes out like this and then
like Maine Coons they had the further
goes oh oh
like they're super fluffy Lanka yellow
here and they big paws more cat talk Joe
yay all right so this is the cat Oh
doesn't look like a mink that looks like
a Maine [ __ ] what
thank you that's great Nick with stripes
super super fluffy he looks like a seal
so this will okay so what it what he's
half man [ __ ] and he's all priority
seating uh he got business class
actually Wow
all right so the owner is the suspect
Raquel McHale and so he posted on
Facebook
he said friends from Moscow who has a
cat of similar color oh because it was
like that
the cat was too fat to for him to catch
him like he was only over here so then
that's when you posted on Facebook and
people came to the rescue and brought a
similar looking cat for this will to
check in with the skinnier cat and then
he ends up switching the cats right
before he boards this house he swish it
because their security is different than
ours because like with ours League do
have security and then the gate so or
maybe at the ticketing ticketing think
Oh cuz he ended up spending a night in
Moscow you probably figure out for your
cat I do a lot of stupid [ __ ] for my dog
yeah yeah so then he but then this fool
ended up posting these photos that I
showed you on Facebook and stuff and so
Aeroflot found out that he did this and
so he ended up taking away nearly
400,000 of his frequent frequent flyer
miles that's a long why if the post day
he's done so people like bragging online
these days I think and the Kelly cool
yeah but now the Russian cat fans are
pissed and so they're just saying that
this is fat shaming oh my the cat it
looks like a seal but how how big can a
cat I mean she doesn't look ginormous he
still fits on his owners lap boy I guess
so the skinnier one was 15 pounds
maybe it's like a carrion rule Oh like
you carry on can't be more than 20 the
airline so once they found out he was 22
pounds they said no he can't not be in
the cabin you could put on like
like where other animals are no other
animals are there - it's too cold down
there
yeah he refused and that's why he ended
up finding a look-alike cats can't he
say it's a service cat service yeah any
animal can be a service animal you could
have a in America and there any on
America could be like this is my anxiety
support honestly though they probably do
help all animal yeah they buy in Russia
they party everyone's a [ __ ] no [ __ ]
pets allowed but you can't be servicing
me like you can't you're not no anxiety
allowed you [ __ ] that's so true oh my
god what is this anxiety you taco yeah
but that cost this guy four hundred
thousand that's uh that's my lure your
cat behind though cuz it was a layover
right so he did the first one but then
the second one that we're like oh no he
can't get on I'd be like [ __ ] mm that's
like losing all your Sephora points and
they're like yeah alright that's worth
it for the cat look at the picture
you're probably gonna frame and put in
his living room you do make a diva
nobody seen just like wow why the cloud
so close for that probably you should
have just cropped it so they couldn't
tell what airline or airplane they were
on cuz this is really [ __ ] yeah
exactly
but who's Mitchell on him what he posted
it on but like a tag the airline oh but
if you're just posting your family sees
it you know like it's not a big deal but
if people are like out here like telling
the airline that's what thank you new
animals ears pop - probably yeah what's
your song
he's living the life he's so cute can
you take all animals in the cabin yeah
little horse a pony on áoneá plain one
yeah I mean in the capable of this cuz I
might be wrong but I think I receive
south-western I feel like so many people
are allergic to cats I didn't know they
were Bing Bing Bing
you're a lots of cats yeah but you're
allergic to alcohol you shouldn't be
allowed in the bar yes I saw a dog at
the airport peeing on the [ __ ] wall
no just the guy walking his dog in a
[ __ ] nun uh this was like in the
States and in the it was like a terrier
or something and he just lifted his leg
and started peeing and I'm thinking like
who the owner try to like go he had like
'wipeys and [ __ ] and then he was like oh
my god and you pulled it out and started
wiping it a bunch of American Airlines
have those pet relief centers now like
almost next to every like smoking place
I see a pet really think you know how
cute have you ever been inside one it
was that smell oh no I didn't smell
because Gina and I went walked in in the
one from Vegas cuz we were just nosy and
it was like this strip of fake grass and
then a tiny little fire hydrant thing go
and then they had like doggy bags and
stuff and yes there was a little pony on
a plane see well oh my god oh that's
really little pony a mini pony or
Shetland pony
Cortney Pony someone has a pig oh my god
let it be on the animal plate I know
instead of being heading there oh hell
yeah rather have to bring your own
animal and I think you could just sit
next to her if you're inside he's
leaving your pet yeah so you know how
like um they ride a [ __ ] ton of scooters
out in Asia right I saw the craziest
[ __ ] thing so I saw a guy and his
girlfriend and in the back the
girlfriend was holding a [ __ ] golden
retriever
that was almost her size so she was
literally holding the [ __ ] golden
retriever on the scooter she was sitting
this way right he was sitting like this
so she was on the side like that holding
the [ __ ] yeah
that motherfucker's legs were out like
that oh my god the balance yeah
he was just chillin I didn't and then
you know what those oh there's also
little dogs people hold little dogs on
there and all that [ __ ] like that oh
there's a ton of babies yeah let's take
their way of commuting right so they're
usually like that's their SUV this
wasn't even like I strapped in baby
there you go then you're just holding a
[ __ ] baby and then they have these
little as baby chairs that they like
kind of rig up to where they have like a
stool in a baby chair and it'll be like
a one-year-old sitting down while the
dad's [ __ ] drive in like this in the
back mom is [ __ ] riding with another
baby Dobie family's on five on our
[ __ ] scooter just go on down is
crazy sometimes a mom's cooking in my
business dude I've seen a lady eat in
the back [ __ ] noodles yeah
Oh get this I saw [ __ ] delivery dude
with the tray on a scooter with the bowl
of noodles he's just holding you just
holding the [ __ ] but then he
didn't have the soup on the side he was
like this and she pulled up and then he
put the [ __ ] tray where the guy was
chilling and then he put the soup in got
paid and drove off what if her nose
itches during the delivery
I don't know man you suck it up yeah
can't do it I posted this one guy he was
riding holding a [ __ ] ladder sorry
yeah and another guy had a mirror like
one guy was riding and then the guy
behind him was holding a [ __ ] mirror
like this joke dude that just shows you
how comfortable we are it's crazy
nah we won't be able to ride out there I
mean it took me a while to start riding
were they all the same uh the same moped
was like boomer guy on the ladder guy no
the ladder guy wasn't another one oh
just like just separate story they're
just trying to cause bad luck to people
Biggles editor yeah it is wild
know though Dobie Dobie dogs that can
just balance to like there'll be a lady
that's just riding and in the back
there'll be like a little chihuahua just
like dogs balance there's a the scooter
we saw in Taiwan where there's two
golden retrievers between the leis and
they're facing each other and when they
get to the red light their tails come
down because it goes on the floor and
the minute they take off the tails come
up like they know it to like oh should I
let's not tell it just constantly did
that little kickstand yeah that's how
with the program they are that's cute
they're so smart
dude there was this one street artist in
Santa Barbara so you know has got a lot
of street artists on the Main Street but
his whole thing was like he had a dog
that had a cat on its back they had a
mouse on the cat's back and the dog
would just walk around and the cat would
be totally chill and the mouse would be
totally chill and he would touch people
take pictures with it but I have never
seen anything like that like you see it
walk by and you're like what the [ __ ]
Emma I need to go interspecies
friendships it's like the [ __ ] I watch
that that's cute
especially like cats don't put up with
[ __ ] I wonder how they trained them
probably sums that my babies they
probably grow up together oh yeah yeah
they don't even know they're different
alan so yeah they were so chill the dog
would just walk around and kinda just
like chillin and the mouse is just like
okay maybe you guys i've never seen any
animals on a plane i think dogs just dog
I've never seen that animal really not
even doc do you have to pay a lot to put
it in the Kevin with you like I think
it's free if it's on your lap if it's a
service animal it's a service like a
carry-on you had to prove it yeah
they're timing up on the laws now like I
think just two years ago they're not
even allowed like baby yeah the 80s and
you're not even allowed to ask them what
their disability is cousin that's
considered like discrimination but now
you can't do that and you have an if
authorities ask you for whatever
disability or illness or whatever thing
you have you have to show them your card
and stuff and the so the dog can't just
be any random dog with a red vest that
you bought online Lee
one on the phone did you ever use it
[ __ ] yeah all the time
I mean not to travel but you know the
building that we lived in in the
beginning we would have them and then
once we got cool with the doorman
we took them off because they knew that
how much I needed me love to get rid of
my size you three don't you weren't
allowed to have animals on your other
place no not really
yeah three big ass dogs
[Music]
you